So, I've downloaded Tor, which looks like a normal web browser...
...and seems to behave like one too.
I can visit any site I like.
But unlike normal web browsers which would register my IP address straightaway,...
...the Tor browser bounces my request to enter the site...
...via several computers around the world,...
...encrypting and decrypting my identification as it goes...
...so that no one knows where the request has come from.
Now that I'm browsing the internet anonymously, certain websites have become accessible.
Websites like the infamous Silk Road.
The Silk Road was one of the first online black markets...
...where you can buy drugs, guns and child pornography.
Two years after starting the site, the founder, Ross Ulbricht was arrested in 2013...
...and sentenced to life in prison for money laundering, drug trafficking, hacking and fraud.
This was quickly followed by a shutdown of its successor, Silk Road 2.0,...
...along with similar sites such as Project Black Flag and Black Market Reloaded.